silber somuncu sagt einfach mal danke
[Musik]
danke deutschland danke dass du immer
noch an die deutsch türkische
freundschaft lauf obwohl ich die türkei
wie scheiße behandelt um sowas der gutes
wie dich zu finden muss man
normalerweise 200 euro die stunde
bezahlen deutschen abgeordneten ihre
eigenen soldaten zu besuchen
totaler skandal müsste man eigentlich
richtig ausrasten oder wie beurteilen
sie diesen vorgang und müssten die
tornados jetzt nicht abgezogen werden
[Musik]
das war starker tobak was lässt sich
daraus die tornados am ende nicht ab
nachher wird erdogan noch sauer und nach
den käfig mit den flüchtlingen auf
außerdem wäre es irgendwie bundeswehr
jetzt aus angelique abzuziehen
wir haben doch gerade erst den ganzen
stützpunkt in der türkei wird eine
deutsche staatsbürgerin messerle tolo
wegen angeblicher terror propaganda
verhaftet und deutschland macht nichts
stattdessen empfangen wir fröhlich den
türkischen wirtschaftsminister der
allerdings ein hervorragender witze
erzähler ist gemeinsam mit ihnen liebe
freunde wollen wir die
rechtsstaatlichkeit und die
menschenrechte auf das höchstmögliche
niveau hier so klingt ein lustiger die
totenmesse
in deutschland sendet nur signale der
schwäche
einige von uns trotteln machen da ja
sogar noch urlaub
hier kam ein geist bei facebook ihr
braucht keine angst zu haben um hierhin
zu fliegen
top restaurant stop stop shopping und
friseure genau und man kommt sofort
tragen weil die ganzen wagen an kunden
im knast sitzen
andererseits kamen geist kann nichts
passieren
die türkei verhaftet ja nur
intellektuelle ganze deutschland weiter
stärken
[Applaus]